foreign
as you know I'm an extreme introvert yes
and I do enjoy being alone and I
realized
that I really like myself
but I like me alone
and here's what I realized I dislike
myself more and more the more I'm around
people and I become increasingly more
insufferable
as I am surrounded by more people
there's this uh moment in one of my
favorite novels called The Pale King
and
the uh it's a play that is taking place
and it's this real avant-garde play
where the audience shows up
and on the stage there's a man who's
sitting at a desk
and he's just uh sitting there doing
paperwork at a desk is he like an
accountant yes okay yeah and there is a
clock behind him right and
he's just doing paperwork five minutes
goes by the audience is just like okay
what's going on 15 minutes goes by a
couple people leave like this is stupid
there's just a accountant at a desk
doing tax returns and then half an hour
goes by now half the audience starts
leaving
and then hour in
everyone leaves
and as soon as the last person walks out
of the auditorium that's when the real
play begins
what if one person stays they just will
never do the play yeah exactly and that
is me I'm the accountant on that stage
I've realized that I really enjoy living
my life
and when I'm with one person I tend to
do fairly well in short bursts when I go
beyond one person for any extended
period of time it drains me so much that
I'm just as boring as that accountant do
you feel that way you know right now
like like with us like you've been with
us now for a solid hour are you are you
feeling like oh I gotta get out of here
yeah once we get past the two or three
hour mark absolutely yeah and what I've
realized though is it's not you I like
me but I dislike me when I'm steeped in
other people it's like if you really
like sandwiches right then I dunk the
sandwich in water and hand it to you
you'd be like oh
that's me I'm a dunked sandwich are you
calling us water
or are you calling us a sandwich
you know you're expressing it in terms
of like I like me when versus I don't
like me as much when I think another way
too uh and I like that way of putting it
but I think another way is thinking
about the the way you enjoy yourself in
the same terms as how you enjoy another
person so like you like Bex
but if we're all hanging out in a group
that limits
how you can enjoy her company you can
only interact with Bex in a way that's
suitable for being in a group but there
is a certain level of enjoyment and
intimacy and connection the two of you
can cultivate when you are alone which
is why we always get to a point where
when we're hanging out with our loved
ones we say you know can I just get some
alone time can I just get some time with
you where it's not all of us hanging out
together that means something and I
think it's the same for ourselves we
need it in different degrees but we
cannot enjoy the person that we are the
same in groups as we can when we are
alone some people need lots of that some
people need a little of that but I think
it's I think it's kind of also true that
you like yourself and you like yourself
so much that you want to make sure you
have the chance to enjoy who you can be
when you're not giving yourself to
others I think Josh is just trying to
express his love in different ways so
instead of saying I love you backs he
says I like me less when I'm with you
laughs
which we don't kink shame around here
I I had this Epiphany
you do that right it's like I water him
oh now my goal is to get get him to do a
split take
I had this Epiphany when I was driving
Ella to school last week and I thought
it was just me and her and I found that
I enjoy Ella much more when it's just me
and Ella when it's me Ella and Bex it's
like when you're trying to juggle and
I'm just not a good juggler of people
right yeah like I've seen Ryan juggle
one ball and it's he's really great at
it I mean I can even jump on two balls
yeah not a euphemism and
and that's where I am I can juggle two
relationships but one of them is me but
as soon as we throw a third one in there
I just trip up and all of a sudden
everything crumbles right yeah and so
when it's me and Bex and Ella I struggle
when it's me and Bex wonderful when it's
just me wonderful when it's just me and
Ella wonderful when it's just me and
Ryan he and I were on the road for a
year straight fine but as soon as we
start out notice how it wasn't wonderful
it was just fine
it was a whole year
going as soon as TK joined us on the
tour everything went down I'm so glad
Josh didn't like drag me down a dark
alley at some point that year and off me
well here's the nice thing TK is this
does put me in my discomfort Zone yeah
and this is the place from which I grow
because yeah it's true I could go do a
solo podcast or it's just me
pontificating into a microphone there
could be a place for that but what I've
realized is that yeah I couldn't do this
seven days a week There's no question I
I couldn't well I could do it but I
wouldn't be happy doing this seven days
a week but I look forward to this now
because of the great amount of space
that we've created between though
because I I would love to podcast every
single day
of the week but I can't do it with a
group of 10 people or whatever not
because of them because I like me better
when I'm not that sandwich submerged in
water
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free